assalamu alaikum are you guys doing a
sheikh mustafa mustard allah turkey you
you have dedicated your life you by
trained mathematician yeah I was a math
major however my profession was in the
engineering field electronics
engineering consultant so I was
searching for my identity and when I
found the truth
actually before I found the truth
although I was born in Michigan and was
raised almost secularism back in Lebanon
I struggled with my own personal
identity so when I
started the search I made a deal with
you show me the truth and I will work
for you he did and I left my career to
dedicate my life for the service of the
game
tell us in summer you talked about the
neighbor you know and then the story
about viewer talking - yeah tell us
about that
yeah so we were at this interfaith
gathering doing an interfaith
Thanksgiving so I was with pastors and
other clergy and you know how big
Christians are and love thy neighbor
about thy neighbor Sarah they were
talking about neighbors and I told this
pastor I said let me tell you something
about neighbors in Islam I said tell me
so I told them I know you guys are big
on
did you know that puck can commit
enjoined upon us to be good left to your
immediate neighbor but seven neighbor
down this is Wow Wow he was astonished
to learn that so yeah this is something
that the prophet sallallaahu Arlene who
sent them had enjoyed that far mostly
good our neighbors knowing that as he
grew up in Arabia people were bad to
their neighbors he transformed not only
the religion of Abraham but also has
from the whole entire society in
it's aspects including being good
neighbors I think this is what we need
in this day in age under this political
climate to reach out to our neighbors to
be really who we are to show who we are
to our neighbors be loving caring kind
to them unfortunately in America from
what I had found out in the 40 years I
lived in America sometimes Americans
like to be alone isolated individual you
know families by themselves and we tend
to be like that sometimes but I think
this is the time now to reach out to our
neighbors to make it a point that I want
to call my name I wanna share with my
neighbor some of the ethnic food that we
make I want to give gifts to them I want
to build the relationship with my
neighbors our neighbors the Nama some
neighbors are talking about listen to
Fox News listen to see and listen to all
sorts of you know stations and news from
outlets that are definitely untrusted
because they're bad Dean they bash
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
we are they going to hear it for usually
when I speak to know
I start with the misinformation about
Islam Allah Muhammad peace be upon him
and then I say well you're gonna hear
you're gonna take it from the horse's
mouth now because I represent my faith
and I can tell you about it so we as
Muslims here have a responsibility to
share that with our neighbors in the
only way we can share that is the way
the Prophet taught us to shared
my nice loving kind yes when you're
hearing it you're connecting and
learning from the Muslims to learn more
call us
[Applause]